pasaron tres semanas antes de que el
gobierno iraní publicara esa
investigación que prometió desde el
primer momento para conocer las razones
del fallecimiento de maxam Y esa joven
curda de 22 años que murió después de
haber sido capturada por la policía de
la moral enteran supuestamente por
llevar mal el vestimenta la vestimenta
islámica esta investigación ha sido
publicada por la organización de
forenses de Irán y ellos aseguran que
macsa no murió como consecuencia de
ningún golpe como se había Asegurado por
algunas versiones incluidas su familia
que dice que dio moretones en su piernas
y algunos doctores que también han
asegurado que la joven fue golpeada de
ellos dicen que esto viene de una
enfermedad de tiempo atrás de cuando
tenía 8 años una enfermedad del corazón
que pudo haber resurgido en ese momento
como consecuencia del estrés en ese
momento tuvo un paro cardíaco que le
impidió seguir respirando y lo que tuvo
grandes consecuencias no solamente en su
cerebro sino en múltiples órganos ellos
también dicen que esto se debe a una
deficiente reanimación respiratoria que
vivió en ese momento cuando estaba
detenida esta joven a estas horas las
redes iraníes se hacen preguntas sobre
realmente sí es cierta esta versión del
gobierno ya han tenido otras versiones
en los últimos días donde las
autoridades han querido Mostrar que
jóvenes que han fallecido lo han hecho
por razones que no tienen que ver con
las protestas mientras que su familia sí
denuncian que por ejemplo una de esas
jóvenes Sí fue golpeada o otra si se
encontraban las protestas a pasar de que
ellos quieren negarlo para mañana están
programadas nuevas manifestaciones en el
país Como protesta a esta muerte de maxa
Mini